[Music]
in tech stocking news submitted by JK
news who the [ __ ] is that
I don't know never on YouTube it's
greater than you is it that's what them
Oh should I failed at math okay all
right sorry
there's like the sign that was in what
kind of classes you take when you like
any class yeah all right cool so and
YouTube greater than whatever so a
mechanic's lien guilty to controlling
his ex-girlfriend's car with a secret
app I need his number controlling you
how what did she die do you guys
remember when people used to start their
cars with like a little button before
they got in it and they thought they
were like so cool well we're like where
it snows my friend has a truck and he
does that because like it gets the Carl
warm and like that makes it not when
you're at a house party in the middle of
nowhere yeah okay and then the car had
those like lights and the spinning rims
but that's lonely why you need it just
show off at a hospital yeah that's what
else are we talking about I mean she
turns a Tesla on and has a battery parks
it yes it's pretty sick too that's one
of the coolest [ __ ] party tricks
who's the guy that talks to himself out
in the parking lot he was having a
full-on conversation with himself I
think you know I didn't see it maybe I'm
sure people have said that about you at
one point she went into like a big
producer that I like didn't get this
audition for mid conversation with her
daughter wit I was having a conversation
with myself and I was like oh [ __ ] hmm
yeah it was awkward you just you just
made her Nikki's point so the story here
it takes place in Australia this 38 year
old man pleaded guilty to stalking his
ex-girlfriend so the two had dated for
six months and he was a mechanic he
worked for Australia's version of
triple-a and so at one point he helped
her buy a Land Rover and so that's how
he was able to obtain her view her
vehicles VIN
so he used the VIN to set up an app
where it would like track where the car
is and it could also control the car
like what app is this yeah I don't know
the gap but she didn't know anything
about this
and so this app would send him live
information about her movements to his
email account and like control what the
steering wheel or like no radio
it just says remotely control the car I
don't know what that meant scariest fun
you know doesn't know what you wonder
but it's good to know it's the VIN
number see that's what you got to be
protective of ladies and gents for
future stalkers and he also bought
spyware and paid a monthly fee to
monitor her phone location [ __ ]
weirdo he really cares about her that
could be I wasn't thinking like that a
flood though it's crazy good because the
victim she works in the field of digital
technology and she was just saying she
said quote I'm passionate about
technology I'm passionate about how
technology can save and improve lives
and have dedicated the last decade of my
career to working on digitally driven
change programs as a professional
working in the industry it has shaken me
learnt to learn what the offender did to
my car is even possible as a victim it
has caused trauma so deep that it's hard
to adequately describe so now she's
saying that so traumatic like she's
really fearful of technology now well as
my friend Lauren Powell would say what
does she have to hide all right she
looks funny she looks really funny um
Lauren Lauren yeah she looks really like
like her peer somebody say no no online
no no I look she's really pretty no
she's nice she look no like oh wait
you're know about Lauren the comedian oh
[ __ ] yeah am i oh I don't know I don't
know what I'm an I don't seems funny no
yeah sorry that's what I meant to say
parents yes alright that's not what I
meant that's not what I meant
no no she like I looked at her online
website and nice all of her stuff is
like she looks really funny
don't change sit don't change don't let
these people change it on the whatever
she you're fine you're fine why is
everyone so sensitive Emily so sensitive
you gotta be careful yeah it depends on
the word it smells funny is different
from looks funny you just say she is
funny she is funny I don't think I did
English either I don't do math I go at
the syntax down now you're good home
school it's great it's amazing I highly
recommend it for you here you're selling
me on it what's this one pac-man
okay I'm sure that's how you teach a
phone tip he teaches like one move on
yeah my was my mom's she kind of gave up
um so wait so getting back to this story
this could have been the guy I stopped
dating Wow but it did I did what's the
weirdest guy you dated
what was the word it should be good one
well well I told you that dating story
didn't you were you gone when I said the
dating is not the railroad or no he's
just being literal no I told you do
heard it it was that funny isn't an
interesting story yeah so I left this
guy to a strip club cuz I'm a nice
person and he I think he like he was
drunk when I arrived on the date which
is really annoying and I Drive really
far for it and I was like oh my gosh and
so we get through the dinner and like he
was just not the guy that I thought he
was I wanted a guy that was on the
business that was from out of town he
flew in from Texas and so I was like oh
this is gonna be like really because we
had a lot of whatever I thought it was
gonna be good and then I found out that
he had a kid hit three baby mamas
instead of two and he didn't want
custody of the third one and you I was
like oh my gosh that smells like done
and he could see it so he starts trying
to reel me back in drunk as a skunk okay
and he's like you know I have two
funerals to go to tomorrow and then in
my mind I'm like is this guy trying to
recruit me to go to funerals with him
cuz he starts out with I know you've
experienced a lot of death and then he's
like I've never experienced that before
and I'm like holy [ __ ] how do I get out
of this gracefully so like the first
thought that came to my
I was I was in Santa Monica and I was
like I'll just drop him off at a strip
club and I did because I'm a nice
considerate person I didn't want to
leave him alone and yes I do want to
know if that stripper ended up going
with him to the funerals because that
would be awesome
so that was kind of weird you read my
mouth yeah awesome a little weird a
little weird yeah there's more to this
story too though okay okay what else did
he do so he so not only has he been
tracking her for months but at one point
he ended up showing up at the foot of
her bed
Oh dairying at Hernan of her apartment
and she said I mean he said he was like
uh well it's your lucky she said she
said that he told her in a low quiet
voice you're lucky it's just me and not
a robber or a bad person to harm you
cause he was just basically you need
protection I could have been protecting
you showing her the flaw in the system
but she had security system was default
eeeh yeah so then she ended up logging
so she lost her phone or something and
she was able to she logged into his
computer to like try to help find it and
that's when he she noticed his emails
and the whole thing about tracking her
car in every movement and so she said
that she was in the shock and feared her
life I believe he would she would look
through his nose like that yeah that's
really shady yeah
that's pretty [ __ ] okay but wait
didn't she lose her phone right so she
was using a computer to find her phone
yeah yeah so she went like her phone
went missing from her car and so she
used her laptop to try and see if they
had been used when she tried to log into
her account his email opened up
revealing the data he was being sent she
was a human birth dad sounds like a like
an error in the system that he used
right like a technical error and
whatever like app that he like but like
you know bugged her phone way right what
stalking system do you use it was called
web watcher hmm that's a good one
I believe you know just so you know all
you need is someone's iPhone or their
their epilady and just what does it do I
am you have to go to my patreon girl and
strapped it and find out you gonna give
the goods away for free yeah but they
don't even know what episode to go to
oldest what did the Joker say if you're
good at something you don't do it for
free right don't tell me that watch it
wait no it was the old Joker okay where
like he does that right before a concert
I would Heath Ledger tells the guy out
the oh that one was on there yeah yeah
you're like why you is there a plan to
watch this by the way or you just yes
still trying
have you seen you haven't seen the Joker
I knew you I know you guys want to see
it yeah yeah we do I'm scared to go in
the theatre why
just like the shooting yeah hasn't
happened yet I think that so back to
this story a notebook was recovered by
the police from this man's old Beach
home that contained the victims personal
details including dates of training
courses she was planning to attend and a
list of places including businesses as
she frequent frequented what is this for
though like is he like planning on
making some big move
he wasn't really dating this girl so it
was really weird too because he there
was also a list of weapons and costings
it was like that show you have you seen
you I tried to watch I couldn't get
through like pass the person don't like
the guy that yeah the last guy that I
dated you do that creepy
good spy on you oh yeah it was weird it
was really weird what did he do I'll
tell you off camera cuz it was that
weird
really yeah yeah can you hint at it for
people very interested on the edge of
their seats
mmm-hmm is that we're not very good at
teasing just so you know I know I know
he like hires the PI for like everything
it was just like creepy like so he had
you like checked out in an investigative
[ __ ] a lot of things it was weird
it was so weird Lee don't you have
anything better to do with your time
like we're not even together yeah what
did you what do what do you think he was
doing it for information is like why
does
I need all this information like what
are you gonna do with it you know what I
mean like I'm not doing anything like
this is so we're not even to get like
guys just like this is not what I'm
interested in entering into like that's
creepy like why can you just ask someone
what they're doing why do you know what
I mean like he could have easily done
that obviously this guy's got some weird
attachment issues so this was while they
were dating yeah for six months they but
only they were only dating that's a lot
did she think it was romantic that he
showed up at the foot of her bed and
like was like it could have been a
robber he was just staring in silence
and then said that in the lowboys like
they're just [ __ ] creepy I don't know
what happened afterwards that your that
is important like how did she react yeah
what I do I don't know she was like
turned on by that
that'd have been okay what's that Bart
if he was naked with a bowtie on I think
it'll be okay
I would have been fine and if you and if
he was moving her body around like this
and making his dick flop in the house
yeah I think would have been completely
normal yeah but he didn't do that did he
he had to stare at her and be all weird
biotic ghostbusters outfit on that's
really weird
so now the courts there they're asking
the court to charge this man of stalking
and that this offenders name should be
placed on the community protection
register for up to 15 years but I think
they're not I think that's fair
yeah did describe his behavior as
premeditated and calculated yeah it's
pretty creepy it's really creepy was he
saying like I was just trying to defend
her I just wanted to make sure she was
safe I don't know it's like he was
trying to like kill her or something or
like become her mm-hmm her it's all
about controlling yeah
yeah that's very like a narcissist thing
to do of control and manipulation and
like even like how he addressed that
like being at the foot of her bed saying
like you know could have been worse like
because she's trying to like shift her
boundaries to where like she needs to be
comfortable being uncomfortable yeah you
know yes thank you those weirdos yeah
not cool we don't never knows where I am
like I was on a walk the other day she's
like I wish you would do that
I'm like I don't know if Steve knows huh
Wow yeah but you're gonna want a unity
oh yeah I was on a walk but he didn't
know that and he came home from the
grocery store and he calls me and I was
like Hello he's like where are you and I
was like I'm on a walk and he was like
you swear and I was like yeah and he's
like I've been I've been walking around
the house for like thirty minutes trying
to find you it's a long time wait hold
on this whole time he thought because I
like spit [ __ ] that Nicky does - I
like to hide and pop out and scare him
for 30 minutes yeah doing this to me
you're taking months off my life I was
very slowly moving through the house
trying to find her before she's kid [ __ ]
go get in showers like did your only
reaction is I know it's not great but
internally it's like a shock to my whole
system externally I'm not a fun person
to scare you ain't around and scared
himself like around the wall thinking I
might be there so I wasn't doing that
[ __ ] that guys do or think I was so
worried cuz I haven't seen you at eight
minutes like all that [ __ ] guys yeah I
was doing there like please don't
[ __ ] scare me man like that's worse
you just say that it was the other thing
whatever